صدمه نفسيه تنتاب من يطلع على اهوال
ارتكبت في النصف الثاني من سبعينيات القرن
الماضي
هنا في عاصمه كمبوديا سجلت واحده من افضع
جرائم نظام الخمير الحمر الذي حول مدرسه
ثانويه الى سجن واستعمل اسره المستشفيات
وسائل تعذيب وقتل لمن يشك في ولائهم من
عناصره
لشبح المعتقل وصندوق الذخيره من اجل قضاء
الحاجه وهذا القضيب المعدني لتثبيت ارجل
الضحيه وقلبها للخلف
ويكون المحقق جالسا على هذا الكرسي ويامر
بتعذيب الناس بالصعق الكهربائي ونزعي
اظافرهم وضربهم وخنقهم
قسمت الفصول الى زنازير انفراديه لاستيعاب
المعتقلين العاديين ومنها خرج اكثر من
ثمانيه عشر الف جثه وفق تقديرات باحثين في
جرائم الاباده خلال اربع سنوات من حكم
الخمير الحمر وسجل كثير من اصحاب هذه
الصور في قوائم المفقودين لم ينجو احد ممن
ادخلوا هذا السجن حسب بعض الوثائق وهو
واحد من 169 سجنا اقامها نظام الخمير
الحمر في مختلف انحاء
كمبودياباده الجماعيه لم تقتصر على السجون
بل استهدفت معظمه فئات المجتمع الكمبودي
حسب الوثائق نفسها
ملايين الوثائق جمعت خلال اكثر من ثلاثين
عاما للحيلوله دون تكرار ما حصل
لو ان جميع المدارس الثانويه درست هذه
المذكرات فانها ستنتج جيلا يفهم جيدا ان
هذه الجرائم يجب الا تتكرر وعندما يصبحون
مسؤولين ومشرعين يتبنوناها في سياساتهم
ويقولون للحكومات الاخرى في اسيان واوروبا
والشرق الاوسط انما حدث في بلادنا يمكن ان
يتكرر عندكم
محنه سومريتي لم تنتهي الا بسقوط نظام
الخمير الحمر
فصار حارس ذاكره يروي ما تعرض له من تعذيب
ويرافق زوار احد اشهر حقول القتل الجماعي
بالقرب من حيث عثر على نحو 350 قبرا
جماعيا
لقد ادت سياسه نظام الخمير الحمر الى
اباده اكثر من مليون شخص
سامر علاوي الجزيره